If we try to navigate to local host,
port 8000 with our web browser, you see that nothing's being loaded.
This either means that we have not started our server yet, or
there is running on a different port.
In our case, we haven't started the server, so let's go ahead and do that.
Switch over to your terminal application.
And first check which directory you're in with the Unix present working
directory command.
You can see here we're in the Udacity home
folder in the data visualization folder.
So this I think's where our files are, but
let's just double check again using the LS Unix command to list the files.
We can see here we have basic_charts.html, which
is the file that contains our HTML and JavaScript to display our visualization.
And we also have world_cup.tsv, our
data file with information about the World Cup games.
Next we need to start the web server to serve both the data file
since D3 uses AJAX to load external files and our HTML file so
that we don't run into any cross origin request issues.
I'll be using Python's built in module,
SimpleHTTPServer, to serve my files on local host port 8000.
As you can see here, Python tells me we're serving HTTP on 0.0.0,
which is an alias for local host and port 8000.